[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
are you there
my angel
this is for you
what did the doctor say
he said the mutations are advancing
my powers are too strong
cletus i'm scared
it's gonna be okay they're going to take
me away
they're sending me to a place
where there are others like me they
can't do that
they can't take you from me you're my
one bright light
i will always love you
[Music]
[Music]
any last words
[Music]
welcome to your new home francis
[Music]
so
your old boyfriend's finally getting
what he deserves
and the world will be a safer place
without him
[Music]
detective mulligan with all due respect
i don't want anything to do with cletus
cassidy well that's too bad because he
only wants to see you in my opinion you
had your chance to cast it and you blew
it
right um so
what does he want maybe he wants to
spill the beans about where the missing
bodies are buried
so you're gonna have to do the right
thing for a change
no
take your tiny hands off of me
we should be out there protecting the
city literally
what
was that
how many times have i told you
that i want you to hide yourself and
when i am working i am serious it is
important you have to show me respect
respect respect okay
cassidy gonna give you the scoop right
[Music]
i will do it i don't like you
let me is happen you
do not deserve
nice things
[Music]
you